hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode 7 video
they did all the things very big spoiler
warning if you have not seen the episode
yet so here we go
there is a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video she's a $20 Amazon gift card so if
you guys didn't see top 5 WTF just go
let's go ahead and start with it
number 5 Glen is alive they open the
episode with him they totally pulled the
bait-and-switch thing even if he didn't
see spoilery behind the scenes stuff you
probably guessed that there was some way
that Glen was gonna survive it was a
great way to open the episode I mean it
was a great scene especially when Edith
throws the bottle down like hey stupid I
said catch but I feel like the reveal
would have worked a lot better if there
hadn't been any behind the scenes
spoilery images that had posted on the
internet or if they hadn't taken him out
of the opening credits and even bigger
than that he didn't go on talking dead
the night that he supposedly died that's
the biggest thing of all like usually
actors when they die will go on talking
dead be like hey yeah I'm really sad
that I had to die
they tell funny stories about how the
show runners told them hey look we're
gonna be killing you next week so I kind
of feel like this was a no-win situation
for The Walking Dead producers like
there was no way people were not gonna
see him walking around on the set so
whatever I give him pass at least they
tried I mean it's not the greatest plot
twist that they've ever gone for but I
think one of the reasons they swung for
the fences with this is because this
whole first half of the season is taking
place within the span of like a single
week almost so because they can't push
forward too much in time they can't
introduce too many things they have to
create drama within the group so it's
like Maggie's pregnant she's gonna have
a baby but we don't know if Glen's alive
is the baby gonna grow up without a dad
what's going on anyone who's been
criticizing this first half of the
season for being too much like season 2
on Hershel's farm you're not super far
off I do think it's better now than it
was then I just hope that they don't
overstay their welcome and on to my
number 4 WTF Carol finds out that Morgan
is hiding someone in a secret basement
really all of Morgan scenes were about
him facing the Jedi councils justice you
can speculate on which ones Carol which
ones Michonne which ones Rick but I
think we all feel like they're in the
right for taking him to task for not
killing the wolves that ended up almost
killing Rick it's not just that they
almost killed Rick it's that they also
lost that car they could have used that
car to lead the walkers away speeding
which we don't know what's going to
happened in that basement now that Carol
knows that the wolf is there it's almost
like we're going back to prison Carol
where she killed Karen because she
thought she was gonna turn if there's a
chance that she could go down Carol will
go into Terminator mode and just take
care of it
the only thing that'll keep you from
turning into a monster is killing that
was such a great way to answer Sam so
dark just so dark but on my number three
WTF Glenn and eat it they make it they
make a great pair just because Enid is
so funny and Klein is so determined you
know we don't have to talk Glenn Glenn
just having to take all of our [ __ ] it's
just practice for whenever Glenn's child
is that age I should actually say that
the bigger surprise for me is that Enid
is still on the show I thought that she
left completely and she is a little bit
more fun with Glenn right now than she
was with Carl on a my number two WTF
though Minnie porchdick
versus Carl looks like it's gonna go
down at least that's what they want us
to think but because of the Glenn bait
and switch I'm just expecting it to go
down some other way for those of you
that have not read the comics it seems
like they're teasing a very big plot
twist that happens to Carl's character
but because it would be super spoilery
if you do want to talk about it you have
read the comics just please use spoiler
tags I say given the way the TV show has
treated storylines in the past it's 5050
odds that mini porchdick will go after
Carl with the gun the other side of that
being that he'll try to save Carl it
just it seems too obvious that they want
you to think that he's going after Carl
with the gun yeah he's super creepy he's
super gun happy so he's definitely gonna
cause some sort of accident but when it
comes to The Walking Dead
they are very misleading just just look
at what happened with Glenn so do not
take the bait right away but I mean
there's still a chance he could try to
shoot Carl and of course out of my
number one WTF the tower comes down
leaving a point of entry for the super
horde and it becomes no way out so
that's that's basically where we are in
the comics for those that are asking the
story arc that the TV show is doing
right now is no way out walkers get in
[ __ ] goes down a bunch of people end up
dying like it definitely thins out the
cast but because it is kind of spoilery
like the characters that end up dying
I'll just say one more time please use
spoiler tags if you want to talk about
comic book storylines specifically but
because next week is the mid-season
finale on Walking Dead there will
definitely be characters dying there
there has not been a mid-season finale
in recent memory
where no one has died the real question
is is like how many of the SafeZone
people like the new characters are they
gonna kill off compare to pre-existing
main characters they totally just saved
Glenn so I think that he's safe but I'm
actually curious to see if they kill off
Morgan just as a way of showing how
there are consequences to not killing
people
he has continually been confronted with
that idea life is precious but some
people do not deserve to live they burn
people Morgan so obviously this wolf who
is like very clearly bent on killing
every single man woman and child in the
safe zone is gonna do something terrible
and I'm wondering if in the chaos of the
super horde getting in Morgan is gonna
go down let me know in the comments
below who do you guys think is gonna die
in the midseason finale main cast and
supporting characters like new safe zone
characters when it's all said and done I
felt like it was a great episode I did
not like the Kalon twist I mean it's a
total bait and switch Game of Thrones is
doing the exact same thing with Jon Snow
but they did the smart thing and did it
with their season finale I feel like
that's acceptable where it's like oh man
we're not gonna we're not gonna find out
if he's still alive because they won't
start filming for another six months so
it's not like there were spoilery images
of him walking around the set within a
couple weeks but that did happen with
Glenn so it's like wait a minute why is
he walking around on set we just saw him
die so it was a great idea on the show's
part to try that I just I feel like it
didn't go over as well as they'd hoped
but the really fun thing that we need to
remember is that they did not answer the
question who radioed for help to Daryl
now Abraham Daryl Sasha still on their
way back to the safe zone so obviously
they're gonna arrive in the mid-season
finale but maybe they'll run afoul of
that new group again
whoo I do think are the Savior's from
the comics they really only announced
the negan casting a little while ago so
I think it's a little too soon to expect
him in episodes I'm not expecting
himself like the latter part of the
season speaking of time delay in episode
it's like you know we're watching
episodes now but they've already filmed
through like the next four or five
episodes Tara right now as we're seeing
her is still super pregnant because the
actress in real life is pregnant but
right now the day I'm posting this video
she's already had the baby so she's like
she's back to normal so if it seems like
Tara has been sneaking a lot of food out
of the pantry it's just because she's
pregnant in real life in related news I
will say congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner
Blake share please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact
info what's gonna happen tomorrow is I
have new Game of Thrones to post and new
Jessica Jones if you guys haven't been
watching that it is awesome you need to
check it out and for those of you that
have been asking about into the badlands
I'm not intending to do videos for that
but it is a really good looking series
they did The Walking Dead fear The
Walking Dead thing where they give it
six episodes and then they either decide
to pick it up for season two or cancel
it forever and it seems like it's doing
pretty well so I think it'll get a
season two but it's a fun show too
while you guys wait for everything to
post you can click here for all my
Walking Dead Season six videos and you
can click here for the Star Wars teaser
that I just posted whole bunch of Maz
Kanata and there's actually a game of
Thrones actress that you might spot
someone that's part of the Rogue
Squadron so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five see
you guys tonight